welcome to the show all right what we
are going to do something that I think
will be very useful to a lot of people
in the audience and this was inspired by
a post on our subreddit by a user named
Ricard 58 and it relates to this
question that's often discussed in
American politics
the right talks about it the left talks
about it although usually in different
terms which is how do we pay for all the
stuff that progressives want to just
give away to people all that free stuff
that somebody has to pay for Medicare
for all
tuition free college paid family
maternity paternity leave the expansion
of Social Security benefits paying for
infrastructure how are we going to pay
for all of those things how are we going
to cover the costs that those programs
and initiatives represent in terms of
the budget on a national scale and I'm
actually going to dig into it today I'm
going to tell you exactly what these
things would cost and exactly how we
could pay for them but before I do that
I think it's really important just to
remind people that a lot of people on
the right who asked that question how
are you going to pay for that they're
asking the question in bad faith we only
ask how to pay for Medicare and tuition
free college we never asked as a country
I'm talking about how are we going to
pay for that war or those missiles that
we are just replacing on an infinite
loop and from from a sort of practical
perspective how we pay for it is simple
Congress authorizes the spending and
then the Treasury actually spends the
money yeah debt exists modern monetary
theory tells us that it's not just good
or bad to deficit spend it depends what
we're spending on and there's a lot of
things we could deficit spend on that
would actually be good for the economy
there's a whole bunch of other rebuttals
but I'm gonna actually play it I'm gonna
play the game at its face in this
segment I'm going to ignore all the
externalities for example the fact that
health care reduces crime and things
like infrastructure reduce pollution and
modernizing transit also does that let's
ignore all of those externalities and
just play the game the
the right claims to want to play which
is how do we pay for it I'm gonna give
you options that you can pick from today
so first let's look at some programs and
what they would cost some of these is
hard to get an exact number because you
have to account for direct costs
indirect costs savings all of that stuff
but here are some numbers we can work
with today all right here's my list of
free stuff from liberals that we've got
to figure out how to pay for Medicare
for all would cost an additional
estimated 1.2 trillion a year we already
spend a lot of money on health care
medicare for all would cost an
additional 1.2 trillion tuition free
public College 80 billion a year paid
family paternal maternal leave based on
some proposals that we've seen in terms
of how it would be calibrated would cost
about 32 billion a year Social Security
expansion about a hundred and twenty
billion a year so what we're talking
about is one point four three two
trillion or if we think in billions
we're talking about fourteen hundred and
thirty two billions let's flip it now
what proposals exist to raise money to
pay for things and after I'll let you
decide which sound more are less
interesting which sound okay or which
don't how to pay for all of that free
stuff liberals want to give you here's
examples then we'll add them up if we
reverse the Bush tax cuts we would raise
four hundred and eighty eight billion
dollars a year if we reverse the Trump
tax cuts we would raise a hundred and
sixty four billion dollars a year if we
ended the wars in Iraq and Afghanistan
we would raise a hundred and twenty
seven billion a year in terms of ideas
to pay specifically for Medicare for all
if we add a 7.5 percent employer payroll
tax on companies but we exempt the first
two million in payroll if you're a
business with a hundred thousand dollars
in payroll you're exempted you pay
nothing the idea is to protect smaller
businesses we could raise three hundred
and ninety it says million but it's
actually billion that does my mistake
and that would on average actually save
businesses nine thousand dollars a year
we could add a four percent tax payer
tax on income it
the first $29,000 a year that would
raise 350 billion a year it would net
save families because remember families
are already paying for premiums and
co-pays and all of that if we did a
carbon tax of 73 dollars per ton on
businesses we could raise 300 billion
dollars a year a wealth tax similar to
what Elizabeth Warren has proposed if
you tax wealth above 50 million dollars
at 2% and wealth above a billion dollars
at 3% you would raise two hundred and
seventy five billion per year some other
ways to raise money if we increase top
marginal tax rates if you create a forty
percent rate between 250 and 500
thousand a year and a forty five percent
rate from half a million to two million
dollars a year and then a it's I believe
suppose to be fifty percent rate between
two and ten million a year and then a
fifty two percent rate above ten million
a year these are taxes on really high
earners you raise a hundred and eighty
billion dollars if we raise the Social
Security payroll cap from currently it's
around one hundred and twenty eight
thousand to two hundred and fifty
thousand you raise a hundred and twenty
billion dollars per year
there are Wall Street speculation taxes
which we could put in place half a
percent on trades 1/10 of a percent on
bonds point zero zero five percent on
derivative trades that would raise fifty
five billion dollars per year we could
look at estate taxes you could do a
forty five percent tax on estates over
three and a half million dollars and
then a fifty percent tax on estates over
ten million dollars fifty five percent
estate tax when you get to fifty million
dollar estates and if people are passing
on estates bigger than a billion dollars
a 77 percent estate tax that would raise
thirty one and a half billion dollars we
could end fossil fuel subsidies that
would raise twenty six billion dollars
there's an accounting measure called
LIFO which means last in first out you
don't have to understand what it is but
that would eliminate that would raise
eleven
two billion and if we raised the
long-term capital gains rate from 15
percent to 20 percent that would raise
five billion dollars now you don't need
nearly all of this stuff this is the
really important thing I've given you
given you a list of a dozen or so ideas
for how you can raise money you might
not like some of that stuff so let's
just pick and choose one configuration
so now let's compare what these programs
would cost versus what we might save
Medicare for all tuition free public
college paid family paternal maternal
leave and the Social Security expansion
we're talking about one point four three
two trillion I'm only picking a few of
those ideas I mentioned to you what if
we eliminated the Bush and Trump tax
cuts did the employer and household tax
that I mentioned exempting of course the
first two million in payroll for
businesses and the first $29,000 in
income for families and raised the
social security cap to two hundred and
fifty thousand that would raise 1.5
trillion dollars you can disagree with
exactly how much money we would raise by
ending the Bush tax cuts maybe you don't
think it's I believe it was four hundred
and eighty eight billion maybe you think
it would only raise 450 for example you
can say you know I don't really want to
raise the social security cap at all
well then replace that with some of the
other ideas I presented but the point is
we have more than enough tools simple
tools to raise the money to cover what
these programs would cost you could even
tweak some of these imagine that you say
well you know what I'm okay with the 4%
tax on households above a certain level
of income but I think the first 75,000
in income should be accepted rather than
the first 29,000 well that's fine do
that and combine it with the top
marginal tax rate idea which I presented
to you we have countless tools and we
have to remember that there are two
approaches when the right says how are
you liberals going to pay for that stuff
if they're talking in bad faith and many
of them are you can say to them we're
you asking how we were going to pay for
optional wars are you questioning how
we're going to pay for all of the
military and defense spending that we do
because if you're not then you're not
even really asking me to take your
question seriously if they genuinely
want to know how are we going to pay for
this stuff you give them the list of 12
to 14 items that I just showed you and
have them pick we have citations for
every single one of the figures I've
presented to you today in the
description for the YouTube clip for
this story my challenge to you is change
my mind because you can disagree with
the necessity of any one of those ideas
you can tell me you don't think it's
fair to for example do the estate tax
change or to put a 4% tax on households
above a certain amount of income but
I've given you so many more options that
are actually needed that anybody who is
seriously going to look at this should
be able to come away and say you know
what I actually think we can raise the
1.4 trillion that we need for the four
programs you've outlined by picking and
choosing just some of the items from the
list that I gave you if I'm wrong here
if I'm missing something then change my
mind
I'm on Twitter at Dee Pakman and the
show is on Twitter at David Pakman show
I look forward to hearing from you